nos preguntan el triángulo 1 es cuántos
metros ya sea más largo o más corto que
el triángulo 2 y aquí está el triángulo
1 que tiene una longitud de un metro
mientras que el triángulo 2 tiene una
longitud digamos en la base de 3 metros
entonces podemos decir que el triángulo
1 es 2 metros
verdad es 2 metros y por supuesto es más
corto verdad no puede ser más largo
porque de hecho es más pequeño así que
el triángulo 1 es dos metros más corto
que el triángulo 2 vamos a ver es
correcto sigamos con la siguiente dice
la línea 1 que es esta que tenemos de
color gris es cuántos metros más largo o
más corto que la línea 2 y la línea 2 es
esta morada de 8 metros entonces podemos
resolver esto fácilmente verdad la línea
1 mide 2
y para llegar a ocho metros necesitamos
6 metros 6 metros muy bien entonces sí
y ahora sólo nos falta determinar si es
más largo más corto pero claramente la
línea 1 es más corta verdad es mucho más
chiquita que esta línea 2 veamos la
respuesta es correcta vamos a hacer otro
par de ejercicios dice el rectángulo 1 y
es este grande que tenemos de este lado
mide cuántos centímetros de largo bueno
aquí esto lo podemos ver fácilmente
porque tenemos una regla así que este
rectángulo tiene una longitud de largo
de siete centímetros bien tiene siete
centímetros de largo y luego dice el
rectángulo 2 mide cuántos centímetros de
largo veamos cómo es el rectángulo 2 y
aquí lo tenemos el rectángulo 2 tiene 2
centímetros de largo muy bien tiene los
centímetros de largo
dos centímetros de largo así que el
rectángulo uno mide cuántos centímetros
más largo o más corto que el rectángulo
2 así que si el primero mide 7
centímetros y el segundo mide 2
centímetros
quiere decir que el primero excede por
cinco centímetros verdad y de hecho es
es es más largo este es mucho más grande
que el rectángulo 2 en cuanto a su
longitud verdad o digamos su largo y de
hecho aquí se puede ver fácilmente por
ejemplo para llegar a 7 necesitamos 1 2
3 4 5 centímetros verdad así que el
rectángulo 1 es 5 centímetros más largo
que el rectángulo 2
hagamos un último ejercicio veamos es
correcto nos dice el patio trasero de
mario es cuántos metros más largo o más
corto que el patio trasero de linda y
aquí tenemos el patio trasero de mario
ok mide 8 metros de largo
y por otro lado tenemos el patio trasero
de linda que tiene 6 metros de largo muy
bien entonces podemos ver que el patio
trasero de mario el patio trasero de
mario es 2 metros más largo que el de
linda verdad es de hecho más grande que
el patio del ind así que es lo vamos a
poner es 2 metros más largo que el patio
trasero de linda y es correcto